I have a little shopping problem I like
to buy stuff I like to buy clothes
jewelry so how can I spend my money the
right way first we need to find out why
do you like it I like swag you know I
got the drip on so yeah but but you got
such a swaggy face you don't need all
those things the biggest thing is it's
more than okay to buy nice things it's
not okay to buy nice things when you
can't afford them so the biggest thing
you need to think about is living within
your means you guys are working hard and
making some paper you can buy some stuff
but don't spend all of it on those kind
of things put some stuff away for
savings for a rainy day but you can
enjoy yourself within your means I got
like sixty dollars in my cart but yeah
well good just spend 35 of it and save
the other 25.